this all right what's more likely time
who's more likely speaking of bill
belichick to get a statue outside of
gillette stadium bill belichick or tom
brady
don't you think it's going to be a combo
i would imagine it's just going to be a
combo so i'm going to say
this
yeah they're going to be together
yeah they'll be together
wouldn't you say that's how they always
do these things
no that's not how they always do these
things the only one i can think of is
doug peterson and nick foles with the
philly philly thing that's outside of
the link i think you put bill belichick
in front of gate a
and brady in front of gate b isn't that
how lombardi and star do it or are they
together
i don't know if they're together right
there's other places nebraska has one
where they're together where it's uh tom
osborne and i think brooke bellinger or
behringer sorry excuse me um yeah wait a
minute wait wait a minute wait a minute
you can't name three quarterbacks
whoever played at nebraska you couldn't
even get the first ones right
brooks bollinger i think no that's
wisconsin dummy
well so who is it then
who is it who is that
he was he when they won the national
title tommy frazier had blood clots he
came in he won seven games uh played i
think half the game in in the title game
and then he tragically actually passed
away in a plane accident two days before
the nfl draft learn some history my
friend
shout out nebraska
all right next what's more likely in his
documentary tom yeah once i dropped that
little fact on you keep moving
no i don't care it's not it's not that
you you misinterpreted my decision to
pivot it came from lack of interest not
dominance go ahead do whatever you're
doing where's your go get your french
press coffee and your shine box
what's more likely in his documentary
tom brady laughs maniacally at a rex
ryan insult or tom brady breaks down in
tears about being competitive what's
more likely i mean it's the latter right
and i know that you have uh you you have
some takes on this this documentary no i
don't have one i just have one take
i'll tell you
i i don't i don't disagree with you
obviously people are in that mindset
because the last dance everyone said
that you know michael jordan had had
final cut i think michael jordan there
still were moments where he didn't look
so great and you can see actually
afterwards some of his teammates are mad
at him
i'm cool with calling these not
documentaries but like movies or
uh i mean they're not they're not full
documentaries when when the subject
being you know at the center of it gets
to produce the thing i totally agree
with you but that doesn't mean people
don't want to watch it and it won't be
interesting it still will be interesting
well it's better than nothing right it's
it's better than not having the
documentary at all but my concern is
that we just tolerate this kind of stuff
where teams and leagues own their own
media and cover themselves and people
don't take a step back and say and i
hope they're smart enough to take a step
back and say wait a minute maybe we're
not getting the full story here same
thing with tom brady's production
company making this and what they the
man in the arena i mean for starters the
name stinks the last dance is awesome
man in the arena what the what the hell
is that even about they don't even play
an arena it's a stadium go ahead
the man in the arena is is a famous
theodore roosevelt quote
the uh mike sherman it's basically the
mike sherman put a jersey on you're not
the man in the arena
i don't like it it's it's actually a
fantastic you should read it try to
learn a little bit so i so you don't
dumb me down
if it has to be explained it's not good
the last day okay we're gonna have to be
explained here it is it is not the
critic who counts not the man who points
out how the strong man stumbles or where
the doer of deeds could have done them
better the credit belongs to the man who
is actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and blood who
strives valiantly who airs who comes
short again and again who spends himself
in a worthy cause who at the best knows
in the end the triumph of high
achievement and who at the worst if he
fails at least fails while daring
greatly so that his place shall never be
with those cold and timid souls who
neither know victory nor defeat like
mike florio
well that's how i know what your plastic
speech
now i know what you read into the mirror
before every coach doug duggarton game
now i know the arena to beat west
virginia last week congratulations all
right stuart smalley your uh what was
give me a story i can quote stuart
smalley but i can't quote teddy
roosevelt whoever said that this has
been illuminating my intelligence versus
yours keeps going yes uh very what's
we've gotten to two of these items we
only have seven left what's more likely
the 49ers have a 1 000 yard rusher or
the rams have a 1 000 yard rusher last
year raheem mostert had 772 for the
49ers todd gurley had eight five seven
for the rams
i still would go with the 49ers just
because they run the ball so much but it
is tough because you know kyle shanahan
is going to go running back by committee
and he's going to use a bunch of
different guys but if i had to guess
right now who is the rams starting court
running back
malcolm brown
i'm gonna go with the 49ers i would
imagine the 49ers probably have a better
offensive line too you know the rams had
a tough tough go of it last year with
with their offensive line so give me the
49ers and kyle shanahan and what he can
draw up
yesterday sean mcveigh said they have
three starting running backs so i agree
with you and i think kyle shanahan likes
to ride the hot hand and he will until
that guy gets injured and then he puts
somebody else in and then that guy gets
the hot hand i think most remember we
thought mostert was going to be dominant
in the super bowl because he had the big
game in the nfc championship and and uh
they they pivoted to someone else so all
right one more
what's more likely jamal adams is an all
pro for the jets in 2020 or he is
playing for a different team what's more
likely
uh all pro i need to be all pro
what do you think yeah
there's a weird vibe there between the
jets and jamal adams there were reports
yesterday that there's an impasse on a
long-term deal he can be very prickly he
can be very temperamental look he's a
great player i just wonder at what point
and all it takes is one day
all all adam gase and or joe douglas
have to do is wake up one day and say
this guy this this one guy is the source
of 85 of our headaches let's just move
on from him not that he's a source of 85
percent of their headaches i'm
exaggerating but at some point they
could just all you have to do is throw
your hands up in the air once and it's
over and my concern is they're going to
throw their hands up in the air
it's jaylen ramsey you know the jaguars
probably didn't want to trade jaylen
ramsey but at some point you just say
you have to trade jaylen ramsey
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports